now javaScript at first glance really
doesn't resemble the same sort of
object-oriented programming languages
that you see in C and C++ code now these
are typically languages that games are
written in NES Super NES Xbox 360 ps3
all had some resemblance of this now
JavaScript provides a way that you can
define a set of variables as well as
functions encapsulated as an object
called a prototype but for game dev
we're really missing the inheritance
factor that is the ability to define
that prototype and then have another one
inherent from it luckily we can
duct-tape JavaScript just enough to make
it look like we're getting classes and
structure definitions now this type of
setup is actually the backbone of how
everything works inside of grits so
before we move on make sure that you're
very very familiar with this type of
programming model